okay so when we do
uh shomonucci on the back uh
strikes here but intention is here down
here
okay so we're gonna lower that
and uh we'll go in there
there's a timing so when my weight
settles
is when i should be at full impact of
the strike
so not settling then my hand
there was a slight delay i just don't
want to hit here
and then my foot but there's a place
where my weight is heavy so when i'm
practicing
on the bag especially a focus mitt i'm
not trying for power i'm trying
for timing and geometry so i'm actually
gonna learn to take my
my flexion out of it and just let the
weight of my hand do everything
okay so if my foot is to the left
you're gonna find that's not the spot
okay it's going to be inside my front
leg
in alignment with my center more or less
okay so my hands up
and just let the weight do it
hey tristan come on
okay so that that's what he's trying for
good wait
okay good
okay all right let's go a very common
mistake
especially when you're trying to find
the internal aspects of the heart
if you have tension in in the lower legs
and then
you can't get a settling down you're
actually light
and energy can't go in and out of you so
and another um so you're very unaware of
that
and then another misconception is if i
feel myself
flexing then i feel powerful
and i feel that i am powerful
because i felt my flexion and this is a
very
incorrect way of assessing so you can
see you barely touch
the back so the what happens when you
add all that flexion is you actually are
slowing down the strike way
prior way prematurely and there's not
much penetration
so of my flat feel and i hit it makes me
feel strong but
it's way better if i just learn to swing
my fist
okay you're going to get way more energy
transference that way
so we'll go to yokomen
and it's the same thing there's going to
be a spot
where this is going to be heavy it's
going to be in alignment with my center
it's not going to be over here with my
foot
my foot should step to the right of yoko
and then same thing just swing the arm
like a mace i kind of feel like you want
your blood to go to your fingertips
and then make sure that the legs are
relaxing
and you just hit that spot comb
bring extra attention to the
tenseness in your lower leg okay
okay so uh you open mind you can of
course throw it to the temple
uh you can draw here on the orbital
socket uh this is always good to the
uh carotid area of the neck and you also
have these rib cages underneath okay
um so it's
it's the beauty of the yoga mat strike
is you don't have to lift the elbow and
expose the rib cage
to uh to hit not not taking anything
away from
uh hooks and crosses and things like
that but there might be a reason why
you're not
wanting to expose yourself uh and so you
uh yoga men can do those things right
for example this this little short hook
might not do anything
but uh yokohama might be able to
generate enough displacing power
that you're getting in there so um
again somewhere here we'll go one just
target awareness one two i
can hit here this way an orbital socket
and then boom here in the rib cage okay
and then one thing to note is the
flexion of your arm
cannot accelerate your arm this is a
mistake the beginner makes again
it's related to if i feel my own flexion
i feel
powerful if i feel flexion i feel like
i'm moving fast
and it's not true so you can't flex this
arm the whole time it will never
move it can't nothing about this is
moving
so you can see that if i'm throwing my
strike and i'm starting to flex that
it's actually slowing me down as i'm
moving so
the the strike is moving more from the
hip the back
uh and the shoulder area right so you
you don't need this
and you don't want that so um
that way your fast food the strike is
very very fast
uh and i'm not doing this kind of stuff
okay
so just target awareness boom one temple
area
boom orbital socket area three
carotid arteries area and boom ribcage
all right let's start
okay then uh uh in this part
position of this body yeah you might
have to play with it a little
um so for example
you close the the knife edge into a
hammer fist
okay and then you're going to have the
ridge of the nose
here clavicle here
and then so shomonucci's going up up and
forget this part of the shomunduchi
and pay attention to this part boom and
you have your
your upward elbow okay so we'll do that
you'll pull
ba
[Music]
okay okay so your your strikes can't be
scoring points uh things must be
displaced or destroyed
okay so um
when i when i uh he's taller than me
so if i come up like this uh there's not
much power in here because it's higher
than i wanted
so that's why i'm bringing him down he's
coming into the elbow
okay so i then this hand
don't leave with your fingers this is a
mascot striker oh
and i hit there it's a pullman coming in
and hitting okay
so it's a plume hit here and at the same
time coming
coming up okay um so you can see like
there's a mass displacement that's
happening okay
uh it's not me just touching him
okay uh same thing so when i do this
shot
when i'm coming down it's it's got to
have my that same settling so it's
actually going to
displace his tissue on his face
okay so when i'm here i'll do i'll do it
on his chest
and there's gonna be a mass displacement
so
you have to have the same setup you're
working in on the bag okay
um if you're shooting for that clavicle
it doesn't do anything if you don't
break it so you can't uh just kind of go
oh i got your clap i called it
it's a displacing strike okay
so my my weight is dropping dropping on
that thing when i hit it okay
so just like when you had the bag
this thing has to hit in that sweet spot
of where is my mouth
dropping same same thing here
has to hit here boom elbow has to hit
down here not up here and then on this
one
boom same thing boom everything has to
move over because boom that's my target
now
okay it's got to be mass displacing